[Applaudissements]
j'adore me balader non dans une planète
inconnue la boue ma mère qui était
institutrice d'école maternelle m'a
appris que pour que des gens des élèves
retiennent ce qu'on leur dit il faut
leur raconter une histoire
alors j'ai essayé ce soir de vous
raconter une histoire
alors il était une fois un jeune lycéen
damien nommé simon qui découvrit
soudainement lors d'une conférence
d'élèves ingénieurs des arts et métiers
dans son lycée que henri verneuil avait
fait les arts et métiers henri verneuil
vous connaissez peut-être pas mais
c'était un peu le le luc besson de
l'époque quoi le dany boon de l'époque
ce mec qui faisait tous les tous les
blockbusters qui te faisait tourner les
plus grands comédiens kab'in delon
belmondo et donc notre jeune lycéen
décida de devenir ingénieur des arts et
métiers et c'est comme ça qu'il devint
ingénieur des arts et métiers
ensuite il travaille à un peu chez
meccano où il inventa mécano
radiocommande mécano piloté par
ordinateur et leurs vins vous à ces
métiers faire une thèse sur la
conception des jouets la vente à une
méthode innovante pour créer de nouveau
joué pendant sa thèse il rencontra le
professeur tara vol caravelle qu'on
nomme aussi le professeur tara bros
pourquoi tarab rose parce que c'était le
premier à avoir inventé la brosse à
dents avec des poils souples
c'est tout les brosses à dents sont
maintenant des avec des poils de
différentes dureté pour mieux nettoyer
les dents et il était aussi co
fondateurs du futuroscope de poitiers et
donc notre jeune docteur
ingénieur des arts et métiers va se
retrouva à angers maître de conférence
où il créera un master sur l'innovation
technologique et l'union européenne
un peu plus tard le professeur travel
pas dire tara bros rencontre à quelqu'un
de très important le ministre de la
recherche françois d'aubert qui était
aussi député maire de laval et qui
demanda aux professeurs taravel devenir
mère professeur qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire en mayenne
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire voilà
pour montrer toute la potentielle
innovante ce territoire et donc les deux
chercheurs proposent air à 10 de la
recherche député-maire françois d'aubert
d'utiliser la réalité virtuelle de
revendiquer la réalité virtuelle et de
créer un parc sur l'arrêté virtuel mais
un parc c'est long à faire donc de créer
un événement dont simon inventa le nom
laval virtual et c'est ainsi qu'en 1999
et bien avec 40 étudiants de de
leicester danger eh bien on créa le
premier
laval virtual avec un grand succès en 99
d'ailleurs le professeur taravel a dit
cette phrase la réalité virtuelle et le
cinéma du 21e siècle mais ne pas il ne
croyait pas si bien dire
parce que 15 16 ans plus tard et bien
c'est une vraie folie une tuerie comme
dirait legends
alors ça a commencé avec facebook
facebook qui a racheté 2 milliards de
dollars une petite start up qui faisait
des casques de réalité virtuelle ou un
peu mieux que cela soit c'était
cardboard vrai casque et puis voilà mark
zuckerberg a devait le mouvement google
s'est mis à revendiquer à dire ce sera
android le système qui va permettre de
faire de la réalité virtuelle
microsoft a sorti lawless un super
casque de réalité augmentée et puis même
apple vous voyez le logo d'apple qui
secrètement nous prépare sûrement
quelque chose de formidable
un peu l'a racheté il ya quelques années
trois ans quatre ans maintenant le
leader européen de la réalité augmentée
mais ta yo et depuis ce temps là hop /
comme chez apple on ne sait plus rien
donc on imagine que l'iphone 8 ou
l'iphone neufs seront peut-être vraiment
le la super plateforme de réalité
augmentée comme apple sait le faire dans
le domaine par mme de la paix à eau ou
de la vidéo
et pendant ce temps là et bien laval
virtual a grossi
cette année ça a été la plus grosse
édition jamais organisée dix sept mille
700 visiteurs sur cinq jours à laval je
déconne laval c'est quand même
c'est une petite ville korem en mayenne
super dynamique mais pas très grande
et qu'est ce qu'on a observé par rapport
àça parlons un peu techno maintenant on
a observé plusieurs choses déjà les
interfaces sont de moins en moins cher
vous voyez là ce que j'ai là c'est quoi
c'est un quart d'heure c'est un bout de
carton il ya deux lentilles dedans on
glisse son smartphone à l'intérieur et
justement les smartphones qu'on a dans
les poches c'est vraiment super puissant
quoi maintenant enfin imaginer il ya 20
ans 30 ans il fallait une pièce entière
pour avoir la puissance qu'on a
maintenant dans la poche
et puis les contenus sont de plus en
plus accessible
d'autant plus avec le nouveau langage le
web vr maintenant qui permet de partager
du contenu réalités virtuelles sur le
web
alors faisons un petit point à laval
virtual tous les ans on organise les
trophées les laval virtual award les
césars de l'arrêté virtuel alors j'ai
pioché quelques exemples pour vous
montrer un peu de tout ce que ça peut
faire la réalité virtuelle pas ce que
pense beaucoup aux jeux vidéo mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres applications par
exemple le grand prix du jury de cette
année
et bien c'est mimer l'action nous a
permis de vivre est infinie donc c'est
une start up qui a créé un système comme
ça où
quand vous le voyez on peut se réunir
avec des collègues avec des amis à
distance ou qu'on soit là c'est le
patron de la start-up un ancien de chez
dassault systèmes
et voilà donc on se réunit on regarde
par exemple on valide un nouveau plan
d'aménagement d'une ville où
d'une usine et puis on peut avoir
différents outils de création par
exemple on est plusieurs à dessiner sur
un même tableau on colle des post it et
c est ce qui est intéressant par rapport
à ce système c'est que c'est plus un
système de laboratoire comme on a pu en
voir beaucoup c'est vraiment une
solution commercialisée maintenant
accessible à toutes les entreprises
autre exemple on a ici toujours pareil
pour le travail collaboratif là vous
plongez au coeur de la maquette c'est au
phare ses métiers ont fait beaucoup de
ces eaux et bien là grâce à un middle vr
qui s'est basé sur une application
développée par clarté à laval eh bien on
partage la maquette numérique et là
c'est une sorte d'alternateur eh bien je
réunis des collègues pareil du travers
le monde où les voisins de bureau etc
je peux me connecter de différentes
manières et puis voilà j'ai toutes les
possibilités de modifier le produit de
faire de l'ingénierie collaborative
encore un autre exemple quand on fait de
l'ingénierie collaborative c'est quand
même intéressant d'avoir le collègue
avec qui échanger n'a par exemple la
imaginons deux ingénieurs qui sont en
train de concevoir une machine spéciale
bah c'est quand même intéressant de
pouvoir échanger avec le collègue lui
dire tiens mais pourquoi ta mis le
compresseur à cet endroit là et c est
donc à ce moment là ont fait apparaître
le collègue et il ya eu pas mal de
travail de fait ce n'est pas la
meilleure façon de le faire apparaître
on a envie de savoir qu'il est là sans
le voir trop en détail ça pourrait même
être gênant et donc la clarté a imaginé
de faire des sorte de shadow dhombres un
de fantômes pour collaborer je parlais
de dassault systèmes tout à l'heure
dassault systèmes a présenté
dreamcatcher alors c'était un outil or
là peut-être plus pour les designers
plus créatifs
alors vous scannez vous même vous vous
scannez dans une position par exemple là
je veux faire une moto je vais me
scanner dans cette position là où une
voiture et puis derrière avec les outils
et d'outils très intuitif et bien je
vais design et un nouveau véhicule
voilà un nouveau produit je peux même
design et un intérieur vous voulez
refaire à l'intérieur vous l'imaginez
une salle de créativité salle de
convivialité voilà
et tout le monde est heureux avec ça
alors ça c'était le domaine un peu de
l'ingénieur domaines arts et métiers
regardons un peu dans le domaine de la
de la formation avec par exemple une
application développée par est une
réalité qui permet à n'importe quel
enseignant d'aller piocher dans une base
de d'applications de réalité virtuelle
différentes représentations
là par exemple le prof parler des
planètes parle de la terre et l'intérêt
j avec les étudiants dans sa salle mais
aussi un étudiant bac était malade à
distance là un des étudiants à un
problème c'est plus démarrer un moteur
diesel donc il va faire appel aux profs
à distance alors le prof est obligé
d'être sur place
cool et donc voilà il l'appelle le prof
vient il sous forme d'avatar et il va
expliquer voilà comment il faut
connecter les les différents câbles je
pense à la tête de delko voilà donc une
autre application de la réalité
virtuelle en formation toujours en
formation
regardons ce qui a été développé va
encore une fois à la vanne à me traiter
de chauvinisme un peu voilà ça c'est un
système qui permet d'entraîner les
équipages sur les bateaux militaires
ceux qui font acquérir les hélicoptères
par exemple et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'on peut changer les
conditions climatiques parce que quand
on entraîne un sur un vrai bateau peut
pas trop choisir les conditions
climatiques vont pas dire ah tiens je
vais te faire une tempête
tiens j'ai de faire une un peu de pluie
eh bien on peut tout régler grâce à la
réalité virtuelle et puis on fait les
mouvements qui vont bien pour valider et
ce qui est intéressant aussi avec la
réalité virtuelle c'est que chacun va à
son rythme
celui qui apprend très vite et bien il
le fera une fois deux fois puisqu'il ya
besoin de plus de temps et bien une fera
autant de fois qu'on veut c'est pas
grave ça coûte pas cher il suffit de
redémarrer l'application pour terminer
dans les dents les exemples un exemple
un peu un peu ludique un peu
vidéo donc ça on en a tous rêvé et bien
c'est d'entrer dans le jeu vidéo est là
c'est une société suisse artanime qui a
créé cette application
alors vous voyez que les les
utilisateurs là où un sac à dos donc il
ya le pc portable dans le dos bientôt on
aura même plus besoin de ça puisqu'il va
des casques des casques sans fil qui
arrive et ce qui est intéressant voyez
ils prennent un objet tangible
là il a lancé à sa partenaire baguette
elle est dans le monde virtuel mais elle
a attrapé directement donc elle été
capturé un temps réel et puis cette
baguette cet objet tangible devient un
objet dans le monde virtuel et ça c'est
très intéressant parce que ça augmente
la sensation de présence dans
l'environnement virtuel la sensation
l'expérience utilisateur parce que en
fait sur quoi on travaille nous à laval
au labo des arts et métiers
on travaille sur l'expérience
utilisateur qui nous intéresse beaucoup
c'est d'étudier
qu'est ce qui va faire que l utilisateur
va avoir une super expérience quand il
met un casque qui va se dire waouh
on recherche le wahoo effect et donc on
étudie les différents facteurs qui
influencent voilà l'expérience
utilisateur et parmi ces facteurs il ya
la présence qui est une sorte de
sensations un sentiment le sentiment de
présence et donc ont défini des modèles
vaste un modèle qu'on avait défini avec
un doctorant indien vous voyez ce modèle
de présence dans le monde réel on est
présent là je suis présent avec vous
vous ressentez ma présence je ressens
votre présence aussi mais dans le monde
virtuel
eh bien on peut être troublé par exemple
on avait fait une expérimentation en
lisant un livre
quelquefois on avait un sentiment de
présence plus fort en étant juste en
train de lire un livre quand on est
passionné dans le roman de quelques fois
dans un jeu vidéo où il y avait tout ce
qui nous plaisait - et on le voit
d'ailleurs sur la courbe il ya une
différence entre les gamer et les non
gamers
1 les gamer ont besoin d'une expérience
utilisateur un peu plus poussé pour se
sentir présents dans l'environnement
virtuel
alors quel est notre objectif ultime
notre graal ce que nous recherchons à
faire et bien l'idée c'est voilà je suis
là et ailleurs
mon esprit est aimée sens sont trompés
par le par le système
et puis j'interagis avec les autres
comme si elle était vraiment là comme si
vraiment présent et tout ça c'est la
présence absolue on recherche la
présence absolue dans un dans un monde
virtuel
on pourrait lui donner un autre nom
c'est le côté la téléportation virtuel
j'aime beaucoup ce non j'aime bien
j'aime bien dire voilà je travaille sur
la téléportation virtuel ça ça fait très
science fiction ça fait très cinéma seul
j'adore alors avant de conclure je
dirais que toutes ces technologies du
virtuel toutes ces nouvelles
technologies changent nos relations
en fait ce sont des nouvelles relations
que nous créons dans le monde des
relations aux autres
1 les autres que ce soit les clients
dans l'entreprise le patient dans le
médical nos élèves on change les
relations aux autres
et puis on change les relations aussi
aux territoires imaginé voilà j'ai envie
d'aller visiter la pyramide de khéops va
peut-être comme à l'est actuellement
comme elle était à l'époque j'ai envie
de visiter une abbaye peut-être notre
dame de paris comment ça se passait au
moment est bien de au moyen âge par
exemple j'ai envie de voir de la vie
donnant des avatars et c'est donc la
relation aux territoires peu de changer
jusqu'à le comment dire la participation
collective
ça change aussi nos relations au travail
puisque le temps et les distances bas
sont un peu chamboulé on va dire en plus
si vous ajoutez une voiture autonome à
une voiture hubert demain autonome et
ben voilà des temps les distances tout
ça c'est ça devient très très
particulier et dernière chose ça change
nos relations au futur parce qu'avec
toutes ces technologies stava une
vitesse folle
vous suivez sur le web va regarder on
est obligé de faire de la veille
technologique en permanence tellement ça
va à grande vitesse et donc on peut
créer des tas de choses assez
incroyables et donc juste pour conclure
mon histoire parce que je vous raconter
une histoire quand même et bien et c'est
ainsi qu'un jour une joyeuse équipe de
chercheurs de laval créèrent la première
expérience de téléportation virtuel les
transformer le monde en un monde joyeux
et fantastique et ils se marièrent et
eurent beaucoup d'enfants
merci
[Applaudissements]